alors tous et vous aujourd'hui aussi et
tout le monde lui a dit dans les loges
je sais pas quoi en penser
comme on lui a dit tu es beau tu es
propres données est-ce que vous avez une
phrase de prédilection pour aller
draguer une fille ou un truc comme ça
c'est combien
[Applaudissements]
jean-michel si on devait faire le
portrait robot de la famille des al
nabawi franchement ils se
rapprocheraient fortement diana belges
adorent le charme oriental comme ça les
débits noir les yeux une bouche pulpeuse
d'efforts quand une salle change
capillairement parlant
ouais y'a quand même l'impact c'est à
dire qu elle l a besoin d'un renouveau
d'un truc on s'en fout des célibataires
ou pas c'est vrai c'est sur les rappels
sont les rapides ou par delà les chiens
il parle de mensonge ou célibataires
vous n'avez pas oui bah open source et
du papier oui je suis célibataire
[Applaudissements]
qui monte est ce que comme ayem pour y
être attirés mensuellement pour un homme
d'une cinquantaine d'années bonne
situation est plus sympathique
il y avait des positions
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
blaringhem avec qui je serai dans dix
ans attendons maintenant la cpi cette
année je suis france travaille alors
pour libérer les hommes de mon âge
encore un pas qu'il ya eu accroche sur
ce plateau est bien celui qui ment et
vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je crois
voilà
mais il va et dites nous la vérité
etes-vous célibataire oui vous êtes
célibataire depuis quand depuis qu'en
comptant longtemps ah ouais vous avez
envie de te trouver l'amour comme tout
le monde quand moi comme tout le monde
est ce que vous pourriez donner sa
chance à jean michel maire ou pas du
tout pour moi je voulais de prévenir que
jean-michel c'est un des meilleurs de
cette équipe il est généreux il est
attentionné il est hyper gentil il est
vrai il est honnête ou
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est plutôt oui oui c'est plutôt
oui c'est plutôt oui
[Applaudissements]
bernier tout de suite j'ai franchement
voulait rester juste processus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais voulez je vous dise
j'y crois